Stars and Stripes for the Secretary of
State as he arrived in a country where
masks in public are mandatory
the fact that Mike Pompeo is here at all
in a global lockdown is significant
designed to demonstrate that these two
countries couldn't be closer but with
masks off for meetings coronavirus was
the first focus you're a great partner
you share information unlike some other
countries that the try not be skiing and
high that information we'll talk about
that country to a dig China but it was
accusations against Iran which dominated
there was something else plaguing our
region which is an unremitting the
Iranian aggression in terror and I want
to express my appreciation for the
strong position that the president and
you and your administration put forward
against Iran Israel 16-month political
deadlock ends this week with the
formation of an unusual government this
man benny counts once Netanyahu's rival
is now his coalition partner and will
take over as Prime Minister in 18 months
in these Korona times it's harder to
read the body language but it's true
that mr. Ganz has been less enthusiastic
about mr. Netanyahu and president
Trump's plans for West Bank annexation
mr. Netanyahu says he will apply Israeli
sovereignty to Jewish settlements in the
West Bank if he follows through on that
rhetoric it will represent a significant
shift in the landscape here it will
enrage Palestinians and while he does
have the support at Donald Trump's
administration he will draw criticism
and condemnation from pretty much
everywhere else globally 20 miles south
of mr. Pompeo s meeting at the same time
in the West Bank city of Hebron
Palestinians were burying a 14 year old
boy shot dead this morning
Israel acknowledged that its forces used
live rounds after Palestinians threw
rocks and firebombs during an operation
to arrest someone
twenty-four hours earlier it was an
Israeli soldier killed a family on the
other side grieving and so this conflict
rumbles on often unnoticed at a low
intensity but there is certainly no
peace process here
mark stone Sky News in Jerusalem